[Music]
what's up guys
it's lunch money time that's right we're
here
hello it's me and paulina remember us
we're back are you people don't forget
that lunch money is now sponsored by
block five
block five is a great company you should
go sign up for an account that's right
block five remember them you can go and
open an account you can deposit crypto
and earn up to eight point six percent
apy
in an inspiring account you can buy and
sell crypto with no fees on their crypto
exchange
or you can take out usd alone and get
your crypto collateral remember those
guys
block five block fight.com
you should go and get an account at
blockfly.com
but hey what's up how are you why are
you acting like a
legume
you know like a like a like a asparagus
all right listen you got you got a comb
over going on making you look like chad
you're just missing the investment you
be on wall street chad
let's get into it okay hey guys
business intelligence for micro micro
strategy michael saylor
keeps putting bitcoin
into oh sorry it keeps putting fiat to
but
to buy bitcoin keeps buying somebody is
shook guys okay
he bought another 10 million dollars of
bitcoin
so hey my guy michael saylor
that's what his bitcoin balance is doing
so we got night over 91
000 bitcoin what up when this thing
rips just rips from 47k to something
else
everyone's going to be like
michael why do you have so many bitcoin
he's going to be like because i told
y'all so goldman sachs did this search
can i have an opinion about michael
sailors
bitcoin purchases i'm happy for him that
he is scooping all the bitcoin
he's not scooping them all he's scooping
them all sorry he ain't gonna get mine
so goldman sachs did a survey and
found that 40 of its clients have
exposure
to cryptocurrencies you got to be rich
to be a goldman sachs client and 40
of the rich goldman sachs clients have
exposure to cryptocurrencies so guess
what that means
soon the other 60 are gonna do it
because the one thing rich people
hate is watching their rich friends get
richer without them participating
they do not like that game and 50
54 of them predicted that the price of
bitcoin will be between 40 000 to 100
000. when it doesn't say okay that was a
weird prediction all right
what other key takeaways include 61
percent of respondents expect the
digital assets to
increase in the next 12 24 months 32
percent were
interested in whatever but this is the
key step
22 believe that bitcoin will be over
100k
in the next 12 months i've been saying
this in 2019
i'm sticking with it 100k by the end of
2021.
put it on the books check the receipts
when it happens y'all could be right
here
and i'll be like hey guys hey remember
me 100k by 2021.
uh mark cuban is going to
begin accepting dogecoin the meme
cryptocurrency
uh for purchases of both tickets and
merchandise
a forbes reporter asked him about
dogecoin and asked whether it's a bad
look for crypto
uh when people are buying it and mark
cuban said no it's not a bad look
dogecoin is less than a dime you can buy
one dollar worth or ten dollars worth
and have fun watching it all day every
day literally
and i say this with all seriousness it's
the best entertainment bang for your
buck available
what is he doing listen you guys might
think that he's trolling
i think i think that mark cuban is going
through
a transition right now we no longer need
to write
be a billionaire mark cuban what we
should be writing is
meme lord mark cuban he's on the train
he gets it he's in for the memes and i
love it
the i mean what other sports team said
you know what
you guys got memes on the internet watch
this we're going to accept your meme
coin as a currency come to our
basketball games
genius this is a genius move
let's talk about genius moves let's meme
lord genius
anthony uh-oh let's
all catch she's on the edge let's talk
about
the era of audio creators that's not
so there is this new company called the
audio collective
that has launched to help build
businesses on clubhouse
as brands rush to leverage the platform
basically um it's formed by about by i
think roughly
40 founding members cat cole is one of
them um
they all have big followings on
clubhouse and
it will offer event planning brand and
consulting and support and community for
creators working in the field
its founders also plan to lobby
clubhouse for stronger moderation
policies better insights and performance
metrics
and monetization tools people on
clubhouse
want to make money for the content that
they create
so what my question here is
is what exactly i don't know i think
it's an agency kind of
or i think it's going to partner with
some of the big clubhouse personalities
and create
uh businesses interesting i think should
i join
well you weren't invited so maybe not
i'll create my own
whole okay i'll call it is the boss
incorporated and then you could be the
boss
p-i-b-i-p-v
okay let's go to the next one catcall is
an absolute gangster anything that cold
does i'm all
automatically long she wins all right
robots are on the sidewalks now robots
have rights in the case of
pennsylvania legislation has granted
them generous
access rights and even classifies them
as
pedestrians so those little rovering
robots
have the same rights as you and i
crossing those streets
one of them robots uh one of these
robots rolls up to me i'm gonna kick it
over no you're not
watch no you're not what's it gonna do
if it comes up in like your legs right
here it's just like running into your
life like get out of here
get off my ankles so the robot
pedestrians can weigh
up to 550 pounds and drive
up to 12 miles an hour i can run faster
than 12 miles an hour
you can't certainly can't walk faster
than that
is not that athletic so she has an
understanding you cannot run 12 miles an
hour you crazy you barely run
three i'm kidding hold on nine minutes
times three
twenty seven wow guys doesn't understand
the whole idea of short distances
versus long distances you said
you said miles per hour
listen if i got to go 80 miles
how long will it take if i got if i go
80 miles an hour
an hour are you sure yeah all right you
assumed so
so if i have to run down the street
and i run at a pace that is
three miles an hour meaning that i will
take me 20 minutes to run for 60
uh 20 minutes to run one mile do you
think that that's the fastest i can run
i don't think that's good math but yes
uh okay so all right
so we're gonna have a conversation after
today normally i got my friday energy
and i'm getting it dampened
like a wet blanket speaking of damp and
wet
um wet no sorry moistest comment was
being
uh censored by youtube and then
he was like oh my god i'm being deleted
by youtube and then somebody named
wet got in there was like we gotta
support you my man like we gonna get you
up there
so we got people in the comments we got
wet and moist working together
yeah i don't know what's happening i
can't wait for dry to show up
all right
[Music]
gonna be that guy all right manzie has a
question
ask oh it's asked lunch money time
hashtag ask elem in the comments below
manzie asks pom why don't you buy any
public
stocks curious why should i buy public
stocks why wouldn't you because all the
property was captured in the private
markets
what advantage do i have in the public
market all these smart people with all
these spreadsheets and all these little
uh what they call it uh spreadsheet
junkies and monkeys and stuff and
they're running around and they're doing
all their calculations they got
they got calculators they got pens they
got fax machines they got
uh people taking pictures in walmart
parking lots to see the cars and all
no i got no advantage there you guys are
smarter than me go play
where do you have an advantage i'm a
people person
i go and i talk to the founders and i go
do it early before all the smart people
find them and i say hey
what do you want to build and the person
says i want to build
x and i say you know what i believe in
you i believe in you
i'm gonna give you some money and when i
believe in him i give him the money and
i say put me to work
put me in coach what do you need help
with that's what i go do and it's
because i have an advantage today i
don't have an advantage in the public
markets because i'm all the little
spreadsheet jockeys and monkeys with the
calculators and stuff
you ever seen these people that work
they got their best with their uh
suit and tie thing going on or they're
like buttoned down that little pen in
their ear
a little pocket protector they got their
little uh glasses they got to keep
putting up because the nerds
they're nerds and nerds ain't cool
when you're trying to compete against
them the nerds are too smart i'm not
competing against the nerds
yeah nerds i don't compete against
nurses i personally
i like going to compete places where
there ain't no competition
there ain't no nerds okay so that's why
i don't know
just literally because i don't have
anything i don't know how to tell you
this but you're really gonna like moises
comment today
i am convinced that you and moister may
be the same person where are you going
go ahead uh all right so you ask them
what public stock how do you know i'm
not moist
that's what i want everyone to know how
do y'all know i'm not voiced and i'm
commenting on my own videos
guys shut this off do not watch this
i do that and the birds fly i put my arm
out like the guys in central park and
the birds
and then i'm like here's the little
birds and you get some food and it
makes it makes all the humans run away
scatter
skedaddle nerds within pocket protectors
so you asked moist about what
stockholm's i think he said stocks
i think well just read the comment
because every word is important in the
comments okay wait wait wait
16. moist counter finally we went from
day 9 to 16 real fast
this is attempt number 10 to make the
comment it keeps getting deleted
i like that you asked this question
because i literally own only one stock
i cashed out my our oh my god my wrath
to put it into crypto oh my god
the one sock i do own is tesla i learned
a lot from my dad and one piece of
advice he's given me about the stock
market is to invest in companies that
fit two criteria
good ownership and you understand and
believe in the value of what they do or
make
i very much admire respect elon musk
moreover tesla makes a high quality car
and i anticipate they will be much more
affordable and common within the next 10
years
going to mars school too moist
you're gonna we might need to start an
asset management business
because that sounds like common sense to
me
and guess what if you're on bitcoin and
tesla you pretty much outperformed
everybody else over the last year
sounds like you're a genius which might
mean that i might be the commenter
moist which means that i'm a genius
don't be taking voices credit
no listen moist is a genius we just
don't know who moist is yet
i've i've made it an executive decision
i haven't told polina this yet
if moist makes it 90 days of commenting
he's coming on the show live
oh on this show we're gonna bring him on
and the first time i talked to moist is
gonna be recorded
on lunch money oh man and hopefully
by the time we go on day 16 big
bitcoin and tesla are gonna be on the
moon
okay we're gonna already have launch
rockets and moist and i gonna be friends
maybe we'll bring wet into the uh mix as
well from the comments
maybe we'll just have a whole if you got
a weird name in the comments we might
just have a whole party for you
what is um what is your question for a
voice for tomorrow
moist if you have to bring
somebody on a date man woman whatever i
don't know
i don't know what politically correct is
anymore but if you gotta bring somebody
on a date
what is your go-to move
what do you mean like restaurant in the
movie
bowling ice skating with nerd with nerds
in
central park do you go for a walk do you
show up flowers
do you uh bring diet coke over and
you're like i'm healthy
like what do you do
perfect date go to
what is it and extra points
if you describe what the conversation's
like like when glenn and i went on a
date for the first
time i was like tell me about your life
i just listened i was just listening and
listening and listening and listening
and listening listen and listen
listen listen listen listen listen and
all i listen to was because
she wouldn't shut up she kept telling me
all this crazy stuff you know what i
kept saying
no you didn't i like that i like that i
like that
do you remember what i like that with
the fake christmas tree
yeah oh yeah you go you should tell that
story actually so whenever i didn't want
to talk
he would ask me a question i didn't want
to talk about certain things
i thought that i was very sly and so i'd
be like
do you think so we've met in december
and i was like there was a christmas
tree there
in the restaurant and i was like do you
do you think that that's a real
christmas tree or do you think that's a
fake and what i say in response
you like answer the question maybe oh so
you're not distracted answer the
question then she was like so what's the
weather like in north carolina you ain't
distracting me answer the question
i'm a tough negotiator all right i was i
was doing life selection i wasn't doing
dating
moist what's the perfect date wet i
don't know who you are but i'm
interested
see ya bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to 8.6
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account go do your own research
there's risk associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends